ومعنا من تل ابيب مراسله الجزيره فاطمه
خمايسي فاطمه نطلع معك على اخر ما وصلت
اليه هذه
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات نعم بالفعل يعني كما تشاهدون
من خلف مئات الاسرائيليين تجمعون هنا في
وسط مدينه تل ابيب في هذه الساحه ايضا
التي تقع مقابل وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
اذا ما اردنا ان نرصد صوره المشهد هنا
نتحدث مئات الاسرائيل
منذ ساعات الامس يحتجون ويطالبون باطلاق
صراح الاسراء الاسرائيليين محتجزين في
قطاع غزه طبعا هنالك ايضا القاء للكلمات
والخطاب عدد من الخطاب الخطابات ايضا من
قبل مسؤولين اسرائيليين طبعا من المتوقع
ايضا في ساعات المساء ان ياتي رئيس الدوله
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرس وان يقوم ايضا
بادلاء تصريحات في بمناسبه مرور 100 يوم
على الحرب طبعا هنا على مستوى الشارع
الاسرائيلي هنالك تعجب كيف وصلت اسرائيل
الى هذا الوضع وكيف مر 100 يوم على هذه
الحرب ولا زال هنالك عدد كبير من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين محتجزين في قطاع غزه طبعا
هذه المظاهره تاتي كنوع من الضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ذوي عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه يقولون بان
ملف اعاده ابنائهم ليس ضمن اولويات
الحكومه الاسرائ وهذا ايضا ينعكس على
المشاحنات التي شهدها البارحه مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي ما بين رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو وما بين وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يف جلنت الذي خرج من
هذا الاجتماع وعاد بعد
وقت لاحق يستانف هذا الاجتماع طبعا هذا
ايضا يتزامن مع تصاريح صادره من الساسه
الاسرائيليين وايضا من الجانب العسكري
الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن تصريح لرئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرسي هفي الذي قال
ان الجيش يقوم بعمليات واسعه في قطاع غزه
من اجل اعاده الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين هناك وان غالبيه هذه العمليات
هي عمليات سريه ولكن اذا ما اردنا ان
نتطرق الى هذه العمليات فاننا نتحدث عن
فشل ونتحدث عن استياء جدا كبير من
قبل هذه العمليات التي اودت بحياه ثلاثه
اسرى اسرائيليين عبر اطلاق الجيش
الاسرائيلي النيران عليهم ايضا البارحه
اعلنت كتائب القسام انها فقدت الاتصال مع
الخليه المسؤوله عن حراسه اربعه
اسرائيليين الذين احتجزوا في العام 2014
وبالتالي هذا الامر ينعكس هنا على المشهد
في الشارع الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن تنظيم
احتجاجات ومظاهرات في مناطق متفرقه في
اسرائيل شمالا في حيفا في القدس وفي تلبيب
وصولا الى بئر السبع جنوبا جميع هذه
الحراكات احتجاجيه تاتي للضغط على صناع
القرار في اسرائيل من اجل وقف الحرب ومن
اجل التوصل الى صفقه جديده تطلق صراح
الاسرى الاسرائيليين طبعا هنالك مظاهرات
اخرى تطالب بوقف كامل للحرب وايضا مظاهرات
اخرى تطالب باقاله الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ويحملون بنيامين نتنياهو
مسؤوليه الحاصل خاصه وان نتحدث عن مرور
مياوم وهذا ينعكس بشكل كبير على الشارع
الاسرائيلي كنقطه اخيره اود ان اختم بها
كان هنالك ايضا اضراب عام شمله المرافق
الاقتصاديه في اسرائيل ما ادى ايضا الى
زياده الضغط والاحتجاج عبر تصعيد هذه
الخطوه فاطمه خميس منب شكرا جزيلا
لك